let's go next to our caller from the six
one seven area code who's calling today
from six one seven a m-- David salute
Vargas how are you oh hey Luke what's
going on I am in covering the Israeli
elections and it sort of made me think
of a question about the 2020 Democratic
primary luke vargas international
correspondent extraordinaire who has
been a guest on the show you know Luke
we can book you as a guest you don't
have to wait on the day I'll be going to
cover the European Parliament elections
in a few months in Europe which is
probably a great time to do that so
we'll put it on the book but let's do it
for now
okay so Benjamin Netanyahu is being
challenged by this guy Benny Gant and
what I think is pretty interesting about
him he's not you know all that liberal
but he's a little bit more centrist than
Netanyahu but what I find is really
unique about this challenge to him is
that he's bringing all of these defense
you know arguments to the table he's a
general he's surrounded by all these IDF
generals and it's sort of weakened
Netanyahu on a point that he's long been
able to to win on which is hey you know
I'm the guy who will deal with terrorism
and right now my hardline peace
proposals you know make sense and all
that stuff and you know now when rockets
are landing in southern Israel it's a
liability for Netanyahu not you know a
strength you know doesn't establish his
incumbent credentials or whatever and so
I sort of wonder obviously you know
taking that back over to the United
States Trump is is you know he dodged
military service all he's alienated all
the generals he brought into the cabinet
but he still is a great actor he wraps
himself in the flag I'm sure he'll
surround himself with troops going into
the twenty twenty election and I just
sort of wonder if this mix of sort of
political centrism and military
credentials could be what finally undoes
Netanyahu I wonder to what extent you
know as Democrats look to try and defeat
Trump national security credentials or
military background or even committee
assignments familiarity with the fence
issues is going to be an important thing
for the Democratic ticket to to feature
in addition to all of the kind of
kitchen table issues that this primary
has mostly been about thus far it's very
curious what you think about that I
don't know I mean so let's see the the
military credentials could be
interesting but it didn't work super
well for John Kerry with george w bush
in fact military
group started targeting John Kerry and
it sort of completely employed in his
face I think that the centrism would be
more concerning to me than the military
part like I think if you can get at this
point I've seen no good case made for
why you need a centrist to defeat Trump
I think that Democrats have tried
centrists for a long time and it hasn't
gone particularly well even when when
the elections have sometimes gone okay
so my biggest concern would not be what
are their military and defense
credentials and committee assignments it
would be let's put up an actual
progressive that's representative of the
views of the Democratic Party if they
have the military credentials great but
I wouldn't take the military credentials
if it also it comes with being a
centrist I think that that's not a good
direction for Democrats that's a well
and then there's always the VP slot too
which is an easy way to slide some of
that experience that accurately put
another connector that actually maybe
even have a better way to do it thank
David all right Luke we'll talk to you
soon and of course go Patriots but not
Robert Kraft he's vile and we know that
at this point all right see you Luke by
the way with a there you go very
reporter esque not even weighing in on
that staying staying objective there